one nutritious thing okay here comes a
nutritious their candy mouth here comes
a nutritious thought guide candy you
want me to say you wanted yeah I'm tired
of getting a deep deep I can't live on
hard candy boys and I'm not running ah
is because I yep
if I joined the Greenies huh that'll
take votes away from the Democrats
alright well maybe I could run with a
Democrat well what does that mean that
that but they would never do that
governor what what do you say well I'm
just saying perhaps I could run with
someone who's already in the Democratic
field that's how you take out Trump and
he's a friend of mine he's a friend of
yours I'm quite fond of Donald I don't
share some of his policies or know that
yeah I live in the Baja six months out
of the year well I like that you would
run against him because you're taller
you're bigger and smaller I couldn't
really oh I as you know I have a
thousand gallons of potable water I'd in
a silo full of tortillas I didn't know
him in the Baja I didn't know that now
own over 300 dogs but most of them are
little dogs terriers why do you own dogs
because I surround myself with dogs and
corn and guns okay why that's my
platform that will be one of my policies
which is what seven years of corn two
guns and three small dogs for everyone
where everyone seven years of corn seven
years not use or how much seven years of
corn would it cost that would bankrupt
the country faster than when the you
know the green new deal and I feel like
seven ears of corn or or the the
national debt how much how many comets
corn in an ear each ears of corn is an
ear of corn right so that would be that
would be I see you don't understand your
corn you probably never served in the
military
they've never had to shuck corn in the
mess hall I had that's the difference
between you and I okay but what does
that you you call yourself an American I
was a Navy SEAL how
you hold your breath underwater me I can
hold no the the okay I don't know
idiotic steampunk grandfather clock
behind you [ __ ] I can hold my breath
for probably two minutes I can hold my
breath for 17 minutes that seems like a
world record I don't know if that's true
well what why are you calling me a liar
I'm not calling you a liar I probably
think that tower seven fell because it
was compromised during the 9/11 terror
I don't want to get into that I fell on
its own okay minutes later yeah I know
that would you like to run for president
with me me
I don't know anybody get me started I
just keep asking people to rally around
me I I don't know the first thing about
running for president well you ran for
governor were governor yeah I kind of
forgot most of that yeah too many cheer
shots
yeah yeah your big fella so so what do
you say Ventura Cal in 2020 I don't
think so I don't have why not I'm just
not interested in blow what are you
doing what are you busy I don't think
that we could win just why why wouldn't
we win yeah because I'm a comedian I've
got skeletons in my closet men they
would find out what a piece of [ __ ] I
had yeah but you'd only be the vice
president
I know but yeah just be like pence I
never go out for dinner with a woman
okay that's all you have to do is the
vice president right stand there you
know we'll put you in some some shoes
with lifts in them yeah so you get close
to me I'm six foot four up and then
we'll run against the Donald he's a
friend of mine okay it'll tell us how to
be them all right has have do we have
that tape on Don Donald Trump the piss
tape Brian yeah well he doesn't exist
yet oh okay all right I just I would do
I just thought we had tape on Donald
Trump talking about thank you
oh yeah wait you mean this dog that's a
[ __ ] that's Bill Clinton saying he's
not alarmed
my wife Michelle yeah pretty good right
I can do any president everybody go
ahead ah [ __ ] man oppa rock obama no no
I already did that go like old go old
real old George Washington I'm George
Washington I will not tell a lie and
that's exactly what he sounds like
no but you can listen Lincoln see I did
you could listen to Andrew Jackson's
podcast he had he had George Washington
on I'm honest Abe pretty good right
I guess so man's right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]